c'est incroyable oui julien non ce que
disait caroil il aurait pu au moins dire
j'ai imaginé que j'aurais pu avoir moi
aussi un ami il ya bien un menteur quand
tu l'avais ça s'excuse et c'est ce qu'il
a dit sur les réseaux d'ailleurs il
s'est excusé en évoquant ses excuses et
willy il était mineur et dit voilà il
avait voulu une chanson romani s'est dit
voilà ça serait l'histoire serait
peut-être voilà en disant qu'il chantait
un copain qui était mineur
malheureusement c'est un copain qui
faisait mineurs ils avaient canaux à
celui mis face à face
attention attention trouvé la protéine
ou un message audio sans gagnant au
bataclan cd mixé lola donc tout de suite
le pot-aux-roses a été découvert il élit
ses excuses le soir même sur facebook
créée à ses métiers comme ça pour les
excuses n'ont aucune valeur et ne boit
pas pour lui c'est scandaleux les la
responsabilité de la production est
engagée c'est pour une fois il a raison
ça suffit ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle ont cédé icahn histoire
pareille c'est une honte
la latte une approche de la raison il
arrive il dit elle était mineure il ya
eu il était mineure en l'occurrence et
une seule mineure quand une histoire
aussi forte et aussi importante tu
vérifies mais là le petit bolide reichen
tout simplement vérifier la semaine
précédente mais une dominion c'est ce
qu'on regardait est bien coté taclant
c'est autre chose c'est le beau tacle au
maître de recherche au niger data moi je
cherche en bois rond
isabelle ferries assurent la production
tente ya eu des vérifs sauter ou des
vérifs en 8 minutes
ben voilà les vérifications et étaient
pas très compliqué à faire mais vu
l'émission toi qui avait relevé sa
maison mais c'est pas mieux
mais l'étoile à boire mais isabelle je
suis d'accord avec vous là dessus mais
lui le pauvre l'armée d'avoir fait que
servir le csa moi je trouve que c'est
désastreux
or c'est un petit con il a 17 ans je
pense qu'il a compris maintenant oui
alors saisir le csa pour ça je trouve
que là aussi ça ne décolle alors c'est
alors moi j'ai fait moi je suis un peu
d'accord avec isabelle je trouve que la
production ne pouvait pas savoir c'est
vrai qu'ici vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec nous mais voilà au moins ils
s'appellent et moi on partira loin sur
une île déserte en faisant bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre chéri